Mama, du bist sicher in uns eingedrungen, als Amerika, ich
in meinem Van, gut von einem Berkeley, denke, ja,
orange, ein paar kürzlich, hol dir den Hooper,
jeder Pin-Mac, du weißt, was sie
angeboten haben
Mandelrutsche auf Ismael-Sprung Allah
verpasst nicht alle deine Hammonds-
Bestrafung durch den Papst. Okay, cooles,
cooles Fahrrad, verbunden mit einem guten Jackson für eine
Japanerin
unermesslich ausrichten meine das ist für reparierbar
oder dagegen sind vorbei Oh
[Applaus]
wir alle sagen, dass Hellseher ein Sucher Hey
Becca Tornados nicht schlecht
oh wirklich gut Diner Gesicht modernisieren Verbot
und folgte unserem Freund
mach weiter doch sieh Susan großartig fang mein lass
mich
[Applaus]
du